[Music]
I'm so excited to be here I'm actually
celebrating something tonight I finally
just slept with my high-school crush but
now he like expects me to go to his
graduation like I know where I'm gonna
be in three years right tomorrow's my
mom's birthday um no don't clap you
don't you don't know her
but I'm bringing her to a soccer game
cuz I wanted to show her what boundaries
look like you know look just like I
don't see him like I know stop calling
my friends it just she's always bragging
about the dumbest stuff you know like
the other day she was like you know I
can still fit in my wedding dress it's
like who cares right I mean it is weird
that she's the same size now as she was
when she was eight months pregnant but I
just
I don't think bragging is right I don't
think it's right I'm supposed to want
kids I don't know if I do I'm 30 I heard
when you're a girl in you're 30 you're
just like I need a baby but I just don't
want to like make anything with my body
but it seems creepy but uh but no I mean
I'm 30 years old you know I think it's
cuz it's what I do for a living you know
I get drunk every night I'm pretty drunk
now thank you but no but the girls I
grew up with they're living normal adult
lives so they call me now and they're
like aim I'm pregnant and I'm still like
what are you gonna do I'm like I'll
Drive you there like no
weird
I should like kids that's my favorite
reality show you know the show Teen Mom
or if you're from the south mom why wait
for a GED that's stupid we all judge
each other
right like I know as soon as I walked
out here you guys were all like oh she's
so beautiful thank you guys so nice that
you were all thinking that I mean I work
really hard but uh but no we do we judge
I've lived in New York my whole life but
he always just like assumed I'm from the
Midwest I've got that look about me
right
it looks like I've milked something
recently I know on the subway I'm
telling you all the time people are
always like are you lost I'm like no
they're like are you Amish I'm like no I
just like wearing this bonnet like why
are you
it's my fault I look dope in a bonnet
Thanks
people think I'm shallow but I'm not
I'd like the guy I'm actually dating
right now he isn't even good-looking
he's not a party's no one's ever like
who's that they're like is he okay
should we call someone I'm like no
that's his face maybe we should call
someone
but I've just never cared about stuff
like that
you know looks who cares right and he's
so rich doesn't really come up but okay
he's cute he is he looks like one of the
guys from The Hills Have Eyes it's
really gross I can't really talk I never
get hit on I never do and I know you
guys like but you're so perfect you guys
are so great I can't believe you guys no
but I don't the only time I get hit on
is last call at the bar right that's it
that's when I'm the belle of the ball
because I have a pulse it's like the
lights go on the men just start pacing
like gorillas they can only see by heat
they're like what is that predator
see some dude a full blackout just start
stumbling toward me like a toddler
learning how to walk pointing at his
crotch like here like I'll get us a cab
[Music]
I'm a good person I am I'm not racist at
all I'm proud of that but I mean racism
it's an issue you know we have to deal
with it like I was talking about this
the other day I was hanging out with all
my black friend and and I'm like two men
BAE or whatever let's talk about it what
was she saying she was like girl like
like I couldn't understand her but she
was pit
[Applause]
I'm like stop yelling we're not at the
movies
[Applause]